How do we choose
the people we fall in love with?
In the modern world,
under the ideology of 'Romanticism'
you're meant above all,
to Trust Your Feelings!
Love is a mutual ecstasy
at finding a beautiful person,
inside and out,
with the rare capacity, to make us happy.
The romantic attitude sounds warm and kind.
It's originators certainly imagined
that it would bring
to an end the sort of
unhappy relationships
that resulted from the
old ways of finding a partner;
the arranged marriage!
The only problem is that this call
for us to trust our instincts
has very often proved to be
a disaster of its own.
Respecting the special feelings
we get around certain people
in night-clubs, or train stations;
at parties or on websites
and that romanticism so
ably celebrated an art
appears not to have led us to be
any happier in our unions
The Medieval couple shackled into marriage
by two royal courts
keen to preserve the sovereignty
of a slice of ancestral land.
Instinct has been little
better than calculation
in underwriting the quality
of our love stories.
There's another school of thought:
this one influenced by psychotherapy
which challenges the notion
that trusting instinct
invariably draws us to those
who will make us happy.
That's because the theory points out
that we don't fail in love
first and foremost
with those who care for us in ideal ways
We fall in love with those who care for
us in familiar ways.
And there might be, a big difference.
Adult love is modeled on a template of love
created in childhood.
And is likely to
be entwined with a range of
problematic attractions
that militate in key ways
against our chances of growth
and happiness, as adults.
We may believe we are seeking
happiness in love
but what we are really after is familiarity
We're looking to recreate
within our adult relationships
the very feelings we knew
so well in childhood
And which were rarely limited
to just tenderness and care.
The love many of us
would've tasted early on
was confused with other perhaps
more destructive dynamics
Feelings of wanting to help an
adult who is out of control
or of being deprived of a parent's warmth.
Or scared of his/her anger
or of not feeling secure enough to
communicate our trickier wishes
How logical then, that we
should as adults find ourselves
rejecting certain candidates
not because they're wrong for us
but because they're a little too right
In a sense of seeming somehow
excessively balanced,
mature, understanding
and reliable
given that in our hearts such
rightness feels foreign and unearned
To choose our partners wisely,
we need to tease out how certain
compulsions to suffering
may be playing themselves out
in our feelings of attraction.
A useful starting place is to ask ourselves
perhaps in the company of a large sheet
of paper, a pen and a free afternoon
what sort of people in the abstract
put us off and what kinds excite us.
To try to trace back qualities to the
people who first loves us in childhood
and to ask ourselves how
much our impulses really
are aligned with things
that might make us happy
We could stand to discover for example
that slightly distant and sadistic people
do always more interesting to us than
the so-called 'nice' ones.
That should make us stop and think.
Our honestly described
reactions are legacies
They are revealing underlying
assumptions we've acquired
that what love for us can feel like.
We may start to get a clearer picture
that our vision of what we're
looking for in another person
might not be in a specially good guide
to our personal happiness.
Examining our emotional histories
we learn that we can't just
be attracted to anyone
we're limited in the types we have
because of certain things that
happened to us in our past.
Even if we can't always
radically shift these pattern
it's useful to know that we're
carrying a ball and chain
It can make us more careful of ourselves
when we feel overwhelmed by a
certainty that we've met the one
after just a few minutes
chatting at the bar.
Or when we're certain someone
is just brawn or boring
even though objectively, they
do have a lot going for them.
Ultimately, we stand to be liberated to
love different people to our initial
types, when we find that
the qualities we like
and the ones we very much fear
can be found in different constellations
from those we encountered in the people
who first thought us about affection
long ago, in a childhood we should strive to understand
and in many ways, free ourselves from.